Ramsey solutions Chris and Jessica are
with us hey guys how are you hi Dave
welcome welcome welcome and you're here
to do your debt-free scream where are
you from
we're from Mableton Georgia May Bolton
in Georgia just west of Atlanta
okay very cool all right and how much
dad have you paid off three hundred and
sixty three thousand dollars Wow okay
and how long did this take about eight
years okay making what kind of money we
started at seventy-five thousand and we
ended up around two Eddie well there's a
little job what happened on the income
you got a real job what do you do for a
living
I've been Unitologist oh well there's
that okay yeah that helps and so you
came out of med school and this was med
school dad I'm guessing almost all about
$9,500 was a car very early on and then
actually 50,000 was a second mortgage on
our house but the remainder was student
loans Wow Wow
and so you just began to tear away at it
as an women you started this eight years
ago but you have been out school eight
year no no school but I was in I was a
resident yeah we first started when I
was just me had an uncommon at
seventy-five thousand and we just we
just we finally decided to do this we
just kind of drew a line in the sand and
said this is what we're a live one I'm
toward debt free and then so she comes
out of residency how long have you been
out of residency just a year oh okay
so the incomes not been that big all
right so that kind of was the icing on
the cake you'd already made a lot of
headway before then hadn't you yes sir
so how much was left a year ago probably
just over a hundred thousand dollars
yeah I was thinking so you'd already
paid off 250
yeah we don't we've been little for a
long time amazing
but how old are you 34 35 and you make
almost $300,000 a year you don't have a
stinking debt in the world yes it's
pretty amazing wow what a wonderful
career path
so what happened what started you guys
on this process eight years ago tell me
that part of the story I say I slowed it
down somebody showed me your stuff
and I started reading it I most the debt
was hers I came home and we made a huge
mistake we've ruined our lives we got
and here's the solution so I start with
the what instead of the why so she
pushed back immediately yeah but just
through a lot of Prayer and just a lot
of other people bringing up your stuff
to her we're slowly got there got her on
board okay I think I had to get past the
guilt I could get the guilt of three
hundred thousand dollars worth of
student loan debt okay and then so what
what helps you do that why how did you
get past it to where you turn the corner
said okay this is not a guilt thing it's
just a numbers thing I'm gonna kill it
well I think I I started to live by two
principles one was contentment not just
with money but with everything it's a
long road to get through Medical School
so you had to be content with every step
and it actually really helped me and
then the other was stewardship and we
had to be good stewards of our money and
our time and our talents and so just
reminded myself of those two things and
ask God to remind me remind me of those
over and over again yeah and he will if
you ask absolutely in a way that's just
relentless actually so that's fun well
congratulations you guys so what's your
what's your big goals with money what is
it you want to do with money
it's whatever God wants us to do we we
were talking about that I I'm the super
nerd out of the engineer and you would
think right those big checks would be
hard mm-hmm and it was a little bit but
not really cuz I we really got to the
point where it's not our money
and we carry that forward I mean it was
work to this point why change but what's
what what is tickling in the back of
your brain that God's talking to you
about that you that you think hey we
need to do this by house travel give
missionaries I don't know we have a
house that we're working on paying off
the rest of it oh oh and so we'd like to
do that and I think yeah I mean I have a
heart of a giver for sure
our goal together is to be able to just
when we see see a need to be able to
meet it yeah and to be intentional about
the needs we meet I've always just
wanted to be the be the guy that sees
somebody who needs a car or here take my
it's just a car and if they really need
it just do it
mm-hmm there'll be just a fun thing to
do don't we'd love to travel that good
very cool well you're gonna be able to
do all that and more congratulations
well done you guys well what do you tell
people the key to paying off three
hundred and sixty three thousand dollars
and eight years is well I mean it was
contentment and stewardship and all
these things but she brought up a really
good point that you know when it's the
two years or whatever emotion you can
hear you so far but emotion wasn't gonna
carry us eight years right and I'm we
did the math we saw it and so we just
changed the principles of our lives
mm-hmm and really saw that you know we
believe proverbs 22:7 we believe that to
the core and I see proverbs 21:5 that
says the plans of the diligent lead to a
profit we gotta have a plan we gotta
work hard there you go
and it sounds like you guys have been
communicating a lot about us too it's
been fantastic for the marriage
absolutely congratulations and who's the
little one well this is little ramsey
David we named it that for you yeah all
right that's not the truth his name is
Grayson ah okay and how old is Grayson
two months yesterday all right that's
perfect that's perfect well
congratulations you guys you got the
world by the tail beautiful baby
beautiful marriage life is good and man
great income and career track life you
got a lot of positive things coming on
the horizon all right Chris and Jessica
from the Atlanta Georgia area three
hundred and sixty three thousand dollars
paid off in eight years making seventy
five all the way to 280 count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream three two
one
gratulations you guys very very well
done